we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a caller asking about
could there be a millennial exodus
coming listen to this
hey david
so do you think it's reasonable to say
that um maybe in the next few years
maybe up to 10 years we could experience
some sort of exodus
of young people say you know
um let's say 1920 to
19 or 20 years old so maybe early 30s uh
you know like young professionals who
just feel described by the way i don't
think a 19 year old now is a millennial
but that doesn't even matter it doesn't
even matter we're still taking the
question bridged
um due to politics in this country
um
so many issues going on uh and they may
want to just live somewhere else
um do you think that that's really gonna
be a possible thing and what do you
think most of the those young people
would go also for the previous caller um
einstein bagels that's that's the place
to go
okay i don't know about the einstein
bagels thing so here's the deal
um
there is no question
that there are
young millennials and then you know the
next generation after that i guess
that's gen z
who are very displeased
generally speaking with the stagnant
wage
student loan debt
right wing politics industrial complex
they're not feeling good about it and
many of them
would love to opt out in different ways
now opting out might be
accepting a sort of more
simple rural life rather than the
typical graduate from college and then
move to or stay in a big city that might
be one element of it
but the reality is most people are going
to need to work and it's pretty
difficult to move to most other
countries that people would want to go
to i mean some of the easier countries
to move to
are countries that are not necessarily
high on the list of places people want
to move to i mean there are there are
countries listen argentina where i was
born it's relatively easy to move to
argentina and eventually find legal
status you can go if you eventually are
able to get employment or start
attending school
you are given a path to legalization it
takes years but you can just sort of do
it but the economy is a shambles and so
why would why would anybody want to do
it doesn't really make any sense
um so while i think the idea is is a
accurate one there's lots of people
young millennials gen z who would love
to say i'm packing it up i'm going to do
something completely different
unless you want to you know
teach english somewhere or join the
peace corps sometimes these are the ways
to do it it's pretty hard to move to a
lot of the places people would want to
to move to and so for that particular
reason i don't think it's going to be a
big thing we have a great bonus show for
you today the senate republicans are now
backtracking after a huge firestorm over
the veterans bill
eastern kentucky flooding has now
caused
37 deaths and there is more rain in the
forecast what is going on what is the
infrastructure situation that is leading
to these deaths and also we have learned
that the sandy hook parents who are the
plaintiffs in the alex jones defamation
case due to safety concerns
they have been isolated with security
during this wacky alex jones trial all
of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com
to get instant access